me now more of John Dickerson's
conversation with President Trump the
Face the Nation
anchor asked the president what he has
learned in his first 100 days on the job
give me another thing you learned that
you're going to adapt and change because
all presidents have to it well I think
things generally tend to go a little bit
slower than you'd like them to go why
just a system it's just a very very
bureaucratic system I think the rules in
Congress and in particular the rules in
the Senate are unbelievably archaic and
slow-moving and in many cases unfair in
many cases you're forced to make deals
that are not the deal you'd make you'd
make a much different kind of a deal
you're forced into situations that you
hate to be forced into John Dickerson
joins us now at the table John good
morning morning Gail it's a very
interesting interview yesterday was very
fascinating to hear him say that he's
had tougher jobs and being president of
the United States
did he elaborate on what that is well he
was doing a little bit of a course
correction because earlier in the
weekend interviews he'd said he didn't
it didn't realize how tough the job
would be and that he thought it would be
easier so I think he was balancing out
his remarks on that but he clearly is
frustrated by the pace of things in the
Senate he's not the first president to
be frustrated by the pace of things in
the Senate that the founders made it
that way they made it to be frustrated
those deals he's talking about are the
compromise that the system forces you
into but you know Woodrow Wilson said a
president can be as big a man as he
wants to be but then he actually got
into the job and what did he do he
complained about those darn senators who
kept forwarding him and what he wanted
to do so this is a presidential the
biggest takeaway for you the biggest
takeaway is that the the president is is
wants to move faster and is bristling
against east you know it was anxious to
show the accomplishments but he wants to
move faster John thank you I know you'll
return throughout this broadcast here at
the White House